it was as easy as singing up for the
Grammys fall I mean it you know anything
they need from us they'll always have
boys to men singer Nathan Morris on
being asked to sing the national anthem
at Friday's Lakers game honoring Kobe
Bryant
[Music]
he deserves a hell of a lot more than
what we can offer so you know we just
give what we got the LA team took on the
Portland Trailblazers in what was the
first game since Kobe and eight others
including his 13 year old daughter
Gianna died in a helicopter crash last
Sunday and the entire court and night
was dedicated to them the main thing is
is is for you know people to remember
and you know the song that was singing
in the national anthem is it's a song
for people to just you know sit back and
reflect you know on whatever you know
but I think for the most part you know
you have other performances beforehand
that are gonna definitely tug at the
heartstrings you know and you know I'm
pretty sure it's gonna be a very sad
night but you know at the same time we
have to celebrate you know his life and
that's what we're doing so you know with
all with all our hearts were gonna
celebrate tonight Sean Nathan and wanye
even shared their favorite memories of
the black mamba while chatting with et
before the game I think it would be
playing at the the the celebrity
basketball game in Philly when he was
doing all those silly tricks people he
got yeah he's doing all those Auto
Street Street basketball the whole game
was fast break right before the draft
you know being fulfilled
you know the hike was all about him so
we were honored enough or privileged
enough to actually play with him in a
charity basketball game and let's put it
this way if you will I don't think I
played basketball since
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
boys two men along with Alicia Keys also
paid tribute to Kobe at the Grammys
delivering an emotional performance of
their 1991 hit it's so hard to say
goodbye to yesterday the same day he
died and Friday's game at the Staples
Center was filled with even more
tributes to Kobe who spent his entire
20-year NBA career playing for the
Lakers
uh sure kicked things off singing
Amazing Grace followed by a cellist who
performed hallelujah while the video
montage of Kobe talking about his love
of basketball his family and his legacy
played on the screens Wiz Khalifa and
Charlie puth performed see you again
during the halftime show
[Music]
and Laker star LeBron James was visibly
emotional as he gave a touching speech
during which he vowed to carry on Kobe's
legacy quote tonight we celebrate the
kid that came here at 18 years of age
retired at 38 and became probably the
best dad that we have seen over the last
three years Kobe's wife Vanessa took to
Instagram shortly after the game to
thank Lakers nation for their touching
tributes she shared this photo alongside
the caption there is no number 24
without number 2 hashtag girl daddy
hashtag daddies girl hashtag my babies
hashtag our Angels Vanessa also posted a
photo of a gorgeous sunset on her IG
stories adding a purple and yellow heart
for the team's colors and on Saturday
she shared this artwork of 13 year old
Gigi writing seeing my baby girls smile
and happy again with a basketball under
her arm wrapped in love just warmed my
heart
earlier this week Vanessa released a
statement on social media expressing her
heartbreak and devastation as well as
her gratitude for the monumental
outpouring of love and condolences
you